hello everyone it's my honor to
introduce our efforts on building a
unified api wrapper to simplify the web
data collection
my name is pae wong i'm a senior phd
student in sfu vancouver
i do research on data management
problems and my colleague william who is
going to show the demo
is also a phd student and he enjoys
contributing to open source project
okay let's get started data collection
is a critical step in data science
lifecycle
web apis are the interface provided by
websites
as a way to access their databases in a
secure manner
web apis make it possible to access rich
data resources
that cover many domains it's very common
to collect data with web apis
here i listed a few example apis that
many of us
are very familiar with the right hand
side is a very popular github repo
that collects many public apis and here
i just
show a part of the domains that those
api cover you can imagine how much data
behind those apis
although a big value accessing such data
resources can require
advanced programming skills to
facilitate the individual users
there are many popular open source api
wrappers in github they basically wrap
up complex api calls
into easy to use python python functions
however to build such a wrapper is
challenging a functioning wrapper needs
to
tackle a few key components first
component would be to build the http
connection with the website server
second to handle the authorization
authorization for the user
so that the user can just pass the
credentials as the function parameters
and pagination which is to combine data
requested from multiple pages into one
function call
concurrency is to accelerate the data
request process with parallelism
implementation
and the wrapper also handles the result
parsing such as converting json results
to a csv file or pandas data frame
there might be other customized
customized ones
and building wrappers for each website
is not only difficult but also not
scalable
what i mean is that existing wrappers
are built in a web specific way without
considering their commonalities
in this way every time the developers
would build a wrapper for a new website
they will need to implement those key
components over and over again
that's huge repetitive engineering
efforts
from the user's perspective because
those those wrappers are customized for
the websites
and uh implemented by different
developers the user will have to learn
how to use a new wrapper
over and over again as well
another way our our vision is to unify
the api rapid building process
so that it saves energy for both
developers and users
and our library is called
dataprep.connector the key idea is to
implement the general components
that are shared among all websites only
once and described
the website's specific information in
configuration files
such as what authorization and the
pagination scheme the website uses
for developers building a new wrapper is
just to write a new configuration file
from the user's perspective they can
query different websites with a very
simple and similar syntax
when they call the functions the library
reads from the configuration file
assemble the request and execute here is
an example of how to search the machine
learning papers in dblp
users users only need to provide the
minimal input like authorization tokens
and query keywords
the process to query the spotify is
pretty much similar
here is how we connect to spotify and
corridor album search api
and the next we will do the demo
thanks pay next i'm going to show you
two features of the connector
it's easy to use in that you can collect
data from a website in three lines of
code
it's also fast to you in that you can
collect data from websites in parallel
now let's imagine we want to collect
data from a website called dbrp
ebrp is a computer science bibliography
website contains publications authors
and venue information
this is a website of dbrp on this
website you can see
the search box here you can input search
keywords to do search for example i can
type in
slightly learning this will return you
the publications that are related to
this search keyword
you can see here it returns 21 matches
of this search
i can also search for cbpr 2020 which is
a computer science
conference focusing on computer vision
now for this search i get 1996 matches
think about what if you want to get the
search data using python
luckily dbrp provides you an api page
which contains three api endpoints
publication search authors search
and manual search it also contains a
bunch of parameters to be
issued along with requests to these api
endpoints
for example you have a parameter queue
for which you can put the query string
in it
for example in our case we can put
cvpr2020 into
s parameter queue it also has parameter
edge which indicates the maximum number
of search results to return for each
request
by default it's 30. with all this being
given it's still not easy
to create python code to issue http
requests and get data
this is because you still need to
manually compose http request
for example you can use a python request
library to do that and also you still
need to pass the response from the
returned neurologist
let's see how we can use connector to
simplify this process
here i first import the connector
function from the data package
and then i use a connect with a
parameter dbrp to create a connector to
the dbrp website
finally i use the query function on this
connector object
with the parameter publication indicates
i want to query the publication endpoint
and also i pass in the search term
cbpr2020
if i run this query it will finish in
one
second let's also take a peek at
the results we get
it's appendix data frame and you can see
all these results inside the data frame
since the query function gives you a
pandas data frame you can directly apply
analysis workflow you are familiar with
on it using pandas
or just persists the data to disk also
notice the highlighted await
at the beginning this is because the
query function returns something lazy
evaluated
applying a weight on that result will
execute the lazy value and returns user
result
connector uses this feature to achieve
parallelism which i will show you later
now let's check out how many records we
gathered
it's 30 instead of 1996 as we saw on the
website
remember that by default ebrp only
returns 30 records per request
but with connector you can also specify
the desired record number you want to
get by specifying the count argument
now i'm going to add a count here
and give it 2000 as the value i run it
again
you see i get exactly 1996 records
this is one of the coolest features of
the connector because this enables us to
get any amount of data without bothering
to understand the api detail
this is because actually dbrp limits the
records to return for each query as 1000
but since we specify 2000 here connector
knows that
it should break it down to two query
instead of one and send them out
simultaneously
after receiving all the responses it
will concatenate the tables into a
single data frame
next i'm going to show you how to enable
the connector to issue requests in
parallel
this time i want to see more papers
related to cppr
what i'm going to do is first copy the
code to here
and then i remove the 2020 from the
query term
and then i increase count to 10 000.
around the query you can notice that
this query executes a little bit slower
this is because we increase the count we
want to get from the
front of the query and this means we
need to issue more requests to the
underlying api
to elevate this problem we also have the
concurrency parameter here
to accelerate the query if you have lots
of requests to send out
by default the setting is one which
means connector will send out the
request
one per second but i if i increase it to
10
it will send out 10 requests in one
second
you see now it takes less than four
seconds to get the data
at this point you might wonder what if
you have a new website how do you add it
to our connector
it's actually fairly easy you only need
to create a config file for that
and then add it to our ripple you can
see this is our ripple
we currently have think hub we have
spotify we have twitter
and other websites besides dbrp and
yield
you can also take a look at the content
of the configuration file
inside the configuration file you mainly
have two sections
one is request another is response the
request section
describes the information that connector
requires to
send the request to the underlying api
for example it contains the uri
the method of the http request and
authorization scheme and other steps
inside the response section it describes
the schema information
which connector will use it to convert
the response into appendage data frame
to further simplify the config creation
we also provide a ui to generate the
configuration file semi automatically
using these two lines of code it will
display a generator ui
inside the jupyter notebook this
generator takes a request
example and it will return your
configuration file
for example you can type in the url of
the request
and also the request parameters and
other information is required to send
out a request
and then click this button the generator
will send out the request and get the
response
and then it will pass the response to
get the schema of the underlying table
and then generates a configuration file
for you after that
you can just use this generated
configuration file to
to send out the requests using the
connector or even better submit to our
ripple so that the community can benefit
from it
that's it i will give a swing back to
pay
okay thanks for watching connector is a
part of the dataprep library
currently we are also developing a few
other cool components such as eda and
cleaning
feel free to check out and finally to
summarize
dataprep.connector is an open source api
wrapper that make web api access easy
it speeds up rapid development process
for developers
and also standardized cost to multiple
apis
as a simple workflow for the users the
project will be possible with our
fantastic contributors
don't forget to start us on github and
give it a try thank you